hi in this module i'm going to talk
about the general strategy for
performing probabilistic inference
injection networks
so recall that the bayesian network
consists of a set of random variables
for example
cold allergies cough
and hgi
and then the bayesian network defines a
direct acyclic graph over these random
variables that capture the qualitative
dependencies
between the variables for example cough
is caused by
old or allergies
gis is caused by allergies alone
quantitatively the bayesian network
specifies a set of local conditional
distribution
of each variable x i given
the parents
of phi
and so in this example i would have
probability of c times probability of a
times probability of each given cna
times probability of i given a
and then when i multiply all these
probabilities uh together
then i get by definition the joint
uh this
probability distribution over all of the
random
in this case i have a joint distribution
over
c
a
h
and i
you can think about the
bayesian network as defining this joint
distribution which is a probabilistic
database
where you can answer questions about
this for example
what is the probability of c given h
equals 1 and i equals 1. generally you
have a bayesian network
some of the variables you
observe as evidence for example
h and i in this case
and another set of variables you are
interested in which are the query
variables
so that way q would be c here
and what we want to produce is
the probability of the query variable's
condition on evidence
normally this is a probability
of q equals q
for each of the values of little q
so the overarching strategy that we're
going to take for performing inference
invasion networks is to convert them
into markov networks which we discussed
inference for
so
recall we're going to walk through this
example
so recall that the joint distribution
over
the variables here
is equal to the simply the product of
the local conditional distributions
by definition of the beijing
but
these local conditional distributions
are non-negative quantities so they can
be interpreted as factors
in the factor graph so let's draw the
factor graph
so here we have the same set of
variables
for every variable we have
a factor corresponding to local
conditional distribution we have
probability of c
probability of a
probability of h given c and a which
connects c a and h
and then probability of i
so
in the factory graph representation
these are simply functions
this is a function that takes depends on
c and h and the factor graph doesn't
really care that it's a local
distribution
so now remember in a markov network
we take a factor graph
and we multiply all the factors together
and we divide by the normalization
constant to get
this product to sum to one
but notice that in this case that the
normalization constant is exactly one
because we
had this equality from the definition of
the bayesian network so z has to be one
in this case
so the bayesian network is just a markov
network with a normalization constant
one
and that means we can take
any major network and
reinterpret it as a markov network and
answer all sorts of marginal queries for
example we can ask for the probability
of a we can ask for the probability of h
and so on
i'll just remind you that
a single factor
connects all the parents
so notice that there are two edges c to
h
a to h here but in the factory graph
representation you should connect
um
the parents and the child into one
okay so
there's only one thing missing from this
picture which is that often in bayesian
networks you want to condition on
evidence
so let's condition on h and i
to do this we're going to define a
markov network
over the non-conditioned variables so in
this case that's going to be c
equals c
a equals a condition on h equals 1 and i
equals 1.
and
what i'm going to do is we're just going
to substitute the values
to of the evidence into the factors
themselves
so here is the factor graph i have only
c and a left
and p of c and p of a is the same
and now we have this factor
that depends on c and a but h is equal
to one so i don't need to represent h as
a variable
and i hear the same i equals one so i
don't need to represent i as x variable
so now i take these four factors
and i multiply them all together
and i get
that is this factor graph and now i need
to normalize
by one over z it's a different z now
in this case
z is not one because i'm conditioning on
evidence
and in particular
z is going to be the probability of the
evidence
and you can see this because this is a
joint this this is a conditional
distribution and conditional
distribution is equal to the joint
distribution
divided by the marginal of the thing
that you're conditioning on
z has to be equal to the marginal
evidence
but nonetheless this is a markov network
and now again we can run any inference
algorithm we like over this markup
network for example gibbs sampling
so let me actually do that in this uh
here
so here is the medical diagnosis we
define variable c
a
h and i
we're gonna condition on h equals one i
equals one
now we're interested in the marginal
probability of c
and we're going to run gibbs sampling
so um if sampling remember it's going to
take opera arbitrary factor graph
or markup network and it's going to go
through an assignment and reassign each
variable one at a time and it's going to
accumulate these counts
let me speed this up a little bit and
say do a thousand steps at a time
and now you can see that these counts
should converge to
the right it's about
0.13 should converge to the right
probability of c
condition on h and i
so then we're kind of done we
have a bayesian network we condition on
evidence
we reform this reduced factor graph
or markov network and then we just run
gibbs sampling
so in some sense we are done but i want
to push this a little bit further and
show how we can leverage the structure
of asian networks to optimize things
so let's take another example where
we're now conditioning on
h
okay so
we're conditioning our h so let's go
through the motions here we're going to
find the markup network on the um
the variables that we didn't condition
on condition on h equals one
and that's going to be equal to just the
product of all the local conditional
distributions where we've substituted
now h equals one
and now the normalization constant is
the probability of the evidence
and now i can ask the question
what is the probability of c equals one
given equals one
this is something that i can just go and
compute using keep sampling
but the question is can we reduce the
markov network before running inference
because if we can get the markup network
to be a little bit smaller
then hopefully inference can be a bit
faster
so the answer is yes and
we're going to show this by doing a
little bit of algebra here so here is
this visual network again
where i've conditioned on h
so now let me
compute the marginal distribution where
i've marginalized that i so here i don't
have i anymore
but i can express this in terms of
this probability of c a and i
where i simply sum out all possible
values of
so this is just the definition of
marginal not marginal probability
so now i can um using the definition of
the bayesian network i can rewrite the
joint distribution
in terms of local conditional
distribution
okay so
and now
i
make an observation which is that
summing over i but none of this actually
depends on i except for this last
factor
so what i can do is
push all this stuff out or equivalently
push the summation inside so now it's
wrapped tightly around this a p of i
given a
now what is this
by definition of local conditional
distributions this is exactly one so it
gets dropped
so now i have this nicer form
but not only is it smaller
let's try to understand what it is it's
this is
the probability of c
probability of a probability of h equals
1 given c and a
so it's as if
this variable i didn't exist at all
so this is a
general idea behind bayesian networks
which is that you can throw away any
unobserved leaves before running
inference
so this is very powerful because
it connects
[Music]
over variables which is generally an
algebraic operation involves a lot of
hard work
with
removal which is a graph operation which
is more intuitive than trivial in this
case
so in general marginalization is hard
but when they are unobserved leaves of a
bayesian network it is trivial just
remove it
so here is another type of structure we
can exploit which is actually not
specific to bayesian networks
it shows up more generally in markup
network
so let's take another example here we're
going to condition on i this time
so
here we're going to define this markup
network where
let's just write down
this query that we're interested in
we're interested in c equals c given i
equals 1 here
and expanding it out based on the
definition of marginal probability um i
can put in probability of c a and h
where i sum over all possible values of
h so i'm marginalizing out a and h here
and by definition of the bayesian
network i can replace this with the
local conditional
distributions
and now using the same trick as before
i notice that
h is an unobserved leave so i can
actually marginalize out h and this
factor disappears graphically this h
disappears
and now i am left with
this
um
asian network
where
notice that
the only thing that
depends on c is this p of c
so i can actually pull it out
and rewrite it as
follows and now i have p of c times some
mess
and the nice thing in this case is that
this mess is just a constant
because it doesn't depend on
z
and moreover because pfc is a
distribution and this left-hand side is
the distribution this constant is
actually one
so
because c graphically c and
this a i
uh sub graph is actually disconnected
which means that i can simply remove
this part
so generally
i can throw away any disconnected
components
before running inference
okay
so
in general
let's summarize here
we've tackled the problem how to perform
probabilistic inference in bayesian
networks by reducing the problem to
inference in markov network
so
to prepare the markov network we're
going to first condition on the evidence
so this is tantamount to substituting
the values of the evidence into the
factors
then we throw away any unobserved leaves
in this case h
we throw away any disconnected
components
but these two are just optimizations
which are totally optional but it'll
often save you some work
now we define a markup network over the
remaining factors
now we just have a factor
graph where we can now run your favorite
inference algorithm so in case it's very
simple as it is the case here you can
just do it manually or if it's
what's remaining is more complicated
then you can do something like sampling
and that's the end
you